wir denken darüber nach eine pipeline zu
sprengen diesen vermeintlichen scherz
hat luisa neubauer gemacht
ein schlechter scherz oder aufruf zu
gewalt
jetzt gerade planen wir wie wir eine
pipeline in die luft jagen
diese schockierende aussage postet luisa
neubauer in ihrer ins tor ich glaube
hier wurde eine rote linie massiv
überschritten denn das was rieser neubau
gesagt hat war offenkundig kein scherz
sie hat sich nämlich auf das buch
berufen das buch das gerade gezeigt
wurde how to blow up pipeline von
andreas mann und sie hat gesagt jesus
maria es ist nur ein buch ja ich glaube
jesus und maria wenn über dieses buch
nicht so glücklich ich hab da heute
nämlich rein gelesen und das ist ein
offener aufruf zur gewalt